- Well, thanks for coming to
Hallucination Detection Live
with LaunchDarkly AI configs.
I'm Scarlett Attensil.
I'm a senior developer educator
with LaunchDarkly, and
I support AI configs.
- And hi, my name is Marek Poliks.
I'm the Head of AI at LaunchDarkly
and the product owner of this thing
that we're gonna talk about here today.
Would really, really love
to, you know, afterwards,
meet you in the hall,
have a little bit more
of a conversation, not only
about the present state
of what we're gonna show you,
but also about the future,
because that's something
I very much care about.
Let's get going.
- All right.
- So, I mean, that's obvious, right?
Like, I mean, we all know
that this is the case.
I would like to think of it
as almost something like a truism.
So, I spent a lot of time
talking to customers,
hundreds and hundreds of customers,
folks that are generating,
that are producing
some kind of generative AI products.
I love to ask them,
like, "What's the thing?"
Like, "What's the thing
that's stopping you
from moving from pre-production
all the way into production,
and then ultimately staying in production
sustainably in some way?"
I like to take all that
data back, collate it,
come back to my team and say,
"Here are the top five things
that are keeping people
from actually moving
their gen-AI products forward.
And the top five is
hallucinations, hallucinations,
hallucinations, right?
Hallucinations are really,
really problematic.
They cost money, they
cost engineering time.
They cost confidence in
the underlying reliability
of the thing that you're trying to build.
They also cost brand equity, right?
They cost the kind of
visibility of your brand
in a way that's really problematic
and can be frustrating.
But I think this is really critical.
Like, it's not like we're
going to solve this problem
necessarily through the
brute-force application
of continuous reinforcement
learning from human feedback.
You cannot solve the
problem of hallucinations
because LLMS do nothing but hallucinate;
that is ontologically what
it is that they are doing.
That's what the generative
in generative AI
functionally means; it
means hallucination.
And moreover, what's so
interesting about hallucinations
is that they're ultimately the thing
that allow generative
AI systems to be able
to deal with the raw
randomness and contingency
of our world.
They're what allow LLMS to deal
with general questions, right,
to be able to deal with unstructured data.
So, it's not that we
necessarily need to solve
for hallucinations within
the actual model itself.
We don't want to drive models
away from their ability
to handle generic conditions.
Rather, we wanna build
systems that are tolerant
to lapses in accuracy.
We wanna build systems
that can automatically heal
from any kind of interruption
of service provision.
We wanna build systems that are capable
of handling accuracy-related exceptions,
preventing them from
ultimately hitting a customer,
and then roll back
into some kind of self-healing
architecture that allows you
to iteratively improve and
prevent that particular type
of error from happening again.
So, on the subject of hallucinations,
I'll push to Scarlett.
- Yeah.
So, even when you think
you nailed it, right,
when your AI is thoroughly
tuned and tested,
there's this problem with model drift.
So, by now, many of you have
probably heard about this study
that was done by Stanford
and UC Berkeley back in 2023.
They ran the same prompt
through GPT-4 over three months.
So, it was the same prompt, same model.
They made zero code changes.
And accuracy on this prime number test,
it decreased from 97.6 down to just 2.4%.
So.
- [Marek] It's really bad. (laughs)
- Right? Yeah.
So, I mean, that's near-perfect precision
that's been degraded
to basically worse than random
guessing in just 90 days.
But this model drift,
it's not really a bug,
as Mark was saying, it's
just the nature of AI,
which means that continuous
monitoring of your AI systems,
it's not optional for teams
who are using AI in production,
it's existential.
So, we all know about the
pressure to move fast with AI,
but there's this particular problem
that makes balancing
speed and safety so hard.
So, raise your hands if you
worry about your AI's accuracy.
- [Marek] Come on, yeah, there we go.
- Right?
So, this cycle, it happens
on multiple levels,
and it happens because
of two fundamental gaps.
First, you have a lack of insight, right?
You can't tell when or why a model
is making a particular decision.
Like, for example, we're
gonna show you a chat bot
that is intended to
answer questions for you
about your health insurance.
And I can't tell when or why that chat bot
might invent section
7.3 of a policy document
that doesn't exist.
And second, you have a lack of control.
So, there's no way to change your AI
without pushing out a full deployment.
You can't try different models
for different user segments,
and fixes often require multiple teams.
So, this is the post-deploy problem,
and this is the problem that
LaunchDarkly AI Config solves.
So, when your features degrade,
how do you find out about it?
As I was saying, these failures,
they occur on three levels,
and I wanna talk to that now.
The first level is this model layer.
So, this is your
provider-controlled territory.
You can think OpenAI, Anthropic,
these model providers push
updates without warning,
and now your perfectly tuned
prompt starts hallucinating.
The next layer we have
is your knowledge layer.
So, for the example we're
gonna walk you through,
for our healthcare chat bot,
we might have a provider directory
that's changing every month.
Maybe our state regulations
could change quarterly.
And if our knowledge base stays static,
then we're compounding
our risk every single day.
And finally, there's the user layer.
So, user query patterns
evolve organically over time.
During month one, your customers
might be still getting
used to your chat bot,
still getting comfortable with it.
They're asking simple questions.
In our example, maybe it's something
like, "What is my dental coverage?"
But by month six, they're
totally comfortable dropping in
their 2000-word medical histories
and expecting a detailed
coverage analysis.
These failures, though,
they're not random,
they actually occur in clusters.
But the key is you can't
just watch aggregate output.
You have to add per-node accountability,
and then you have to treat observability
like it's a lagging indicator.
You wanna inject evaluators in step,
so they can monitor your agents
and catch issues as they arise,
not after customers are affected.
So, now I wanna talk to you
about why the traditional
principles that we use,
that we rely on for software engineering
often fail when it comes to AI.
So, the deterministic code is predictable.
Okay.
Thank you. Go ahead.
Is it this one?
- [Marek] Yeah.
- Okay, so it's predictable, right?
So, if you call a function
with the same parameters,
you know you're gonna
get identical results
every single time.
You can test it once, and
you can trust it forever.
Traditional code is also reproducible.
So, you've got your
gate commits, rollbacks,
version control, equals behavior control.
I know what code is running,
when it changed, and who changed it.
And this means I can predict
how that code's gonna behave.
Finally, it's traceable.
If there's a bug, you can
walk through your code,
you can figure out exactly
where the error is occurring
and fix the problem.
And these principles work great
for deterministic systems,
but as you know, AI is stochastic.
So, it's dynamic, right?
You can't unit-test
creativity or reasoning;
you have to use an entirely
different testing methodology.
Like, there's no assertion
for, "Sounds empathetic"
or "Explains clearly;" it's evolving.
So, we can pin to a specific model,
but as we just saw, that doesn't mean
it's gonna behave the same way today
as it did three months ago.
And finally, it's opaque.
Our solutions are composed of
black boxes chained together,
and we have no way to tell
when or why these models
made the decisions they made.
We're not just shipping code anymore,
we're shipping statistical models,
and deterministic
deployment strategies fail
for these probabilistic systems.
That's when LaunchDarkly
AI configs comes in.
So, Marek's gonna walk
you through the demo now.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'm gonna contextualize
the demo a little bit first
before I actually show it to you,
and I'll give you also a little
bit of a diagram to show you
materially what it is that I'm doing.
We're gonna do three different
types of demos that highlight
what I think is ultimately
an integrated circuit;
one that's ultimately
trying to solve the problem
of how do you build a system
that's constantly self-optimizing
for accuracy in real time,
like really in the moment,
before you see any kind of slip ups
in a customer-facing way.
So, the three kind of
components of this mechanism,
the first is real-time control.
And I think this is
incredibly, incredibly special
in terms of what it is
that we specifically offer.
This is basically the ability
to modulate, to change,
to alter the constituent components
of an AI agent in real
time without ever needing
to redeploy underlying application.
This is useful naively in pre-production,
in that, like, you need the
ability to create a variety
of different variations of
an agent, a test, permute,
look at validate, et cetera.
But it's extremely also
useful in production,
where something bad might happen.
And you need the ability
to quickly alter the state
of some agent in a production
context, based on feedback.
Second thing we're gonna talk
about is experimentation.
I really believe so, so strongly
that, when you're working
with probabilistic systems,
you need to be working
with probabilistic technology.
You need to be really working
with statistics at scale
to assess the components,
the performance of a variety
of different agent morphologies over time.
And then, the third bit, I'm gonna talk
about self-healing AI,
what our perspective is
for a self-healing agentic system,
what it means to catch
hallucinations in production,
to ultimately revert to a known good,
and then to pass feedback into a system
that allows for automatic correction.
So, with real-time control,
I'm gonna start with this,
and it's such an ugly diagram,
and it also is, like, such a
thing that I'm so, so proud of.
I wanna start maybe with,
like, a serious provocation,
like, I think actually a
pretty serious provocation,
which is that all the stuff
that you use to build an agent,
to actually compose the
AI parts of an agent,
the prompts, the tools that
you're calling, the model,
hyper parameters, maybe even the models
that you're invoking,
specifically the model providers,
even the relationships or
the topology of an agent;
I don't think that's code.
Like, I really don't believe that's code,
and I don't believe that's code
for a number of different reasons,
of the first being that
these are individual things,
that you are likely gonna change
an order of magnitude more
and an order of magnitude
faster, requires more dexterity
and alacrity in order to
actually take advantage
of this non-deterministic
relationship that you're building.
The second reason I don't
think that it's code
is that it requires an order
of magnitude more vigilant
in its own kind of highly specialized way.
And this ultimately
has to do with the fact
that, ontologically,
these things aren't code,
and that they're ultimately not moving
to produce some ultimately
determined outcome,
they're rather a series of
interpreted instructions
by an association machine.
And so, the provocation I wanna ask
is, like, why would you
subject these things,
these components to the
same infrastructures,
to the same timescales,
to the same rituals that
we place around code?
No, I think that there's
something different.
I think, actually,
and this is obviously pretty self-serving,
I think they start to
look actually quite a lot
like configurations.
And ultimately, I think they
start to look quite a lot
like feature flags.
So, that's something I'm
really excited about.
I joined LaunchDarkly principally
because LaunchDarkly is a
feature-flagging company.
If you're unfamiliar with LaunchDarkly,
it actually completely doesn't matter
from this conversation,
apart from the fact
that we serve almost 50 trillion
feature flags every day.
Those are feature flags
that contain information
that could be used to modulate, to change,
to vary different experiences
of an application.
So, then the question is, what
if you use that to modulate,
to change, to alter the
behaviors of an AI agent?
The way that this actually looks,
the way this actually works here
is that you have applications,
those applications are running,
those applications are making model calls,
probably lots of different model calls.
What happens if you,
instead of hard coding,
all of the parameters that
goes into those model calls,
or instead of bearing them
in, like, large configuration
files or offloading them
to some kind of third-party
intermediary gateway,
what happens if you just stream it?
What happens if you stream it
as streamable configurations
through the form of feature flags?
That means that you're able
to, without ever redeploying
the underlying application,
you can change the prompt,
you can change the tools
that are being invoked,
you can change the
models that you're using,
you can change the hyper
parameters that you're calling.
That's really useful.
You never need to redeploy
the underlying application.
Another bit that I think
is really important
is that your application
knows who it's talking to.
It's aware of the context that it's in.
Therefore, you can
actually dynamically serve
the agent particularities, parameters,
configurations that are desired
for that end customer on demand
because you can just
request the feature flag
that is associated with that context.
This brings me to my second provocation.
So, the first is that this
stuff is in code, right?
That, instead, it should look something
more like feature flags.
The second provocation is
that, this is kind of yields
to what Scarlett was saying.
Just, like, working on an AI
agent, like, you have a thing,
you have a series of parameters.
You're gonna, like, agree
that this is the right one,
then you're gonna unit test it.
You're gonna test it a
couple thousand times.
You're gonna see that it works.
You're gonna see that maybe
there's some problems with it,
and then you're gonna go back
and iteratively refine it.
So, you're gonna work in
a single stream, this way,
to progressively create
and improve that AI agent.
But I really truly believe
that an AI agent configuration
is always multiple.
There's no such thing
as a single instance,
a single configuration
setting for an AI agent.
It doesn't make sense.
These are genetic kinds of creatures.
They should always be multiple,
in that they should always contain
many, many different variations
that you can be statistically
testing against.
That's, for us, really the right way
to iteratively improve an
AI agent in production.
And so, our approach here
is that, not only are we
constantly dynamically streaming
these flags that allow
you to constantly change
and even vary and deliver
different versions of an AI agent
to different destinations,
but all of the metrics,
all of the associated performance
components can go back
into our platform and
allow you to then see
how your configuration did.
That includes things like
how performant was it?
Is it fast?
Is it expensive? How
many tokens does it use?
Are users happy or sad about it?
But it could also include
instep evaluations.
So, we serve online evaluators
and offline evaluators, too, that return
LLM-as-judge evaluations in-step
with that metrics pipeline.
We also return open elemetry style traces,
so full LLM observability, as
well as standard observability
because LaunchDarkly
is a, you know, very much
established DevOps platform
that is very good at doing observability.
And then, really critically, any metrics,
any metric you like,
because it's all numeric
or Boolean data at the end of the day.
So, you can create a
metric that's associated
with some desired customer
behavior, some thing
that you're trying to
motivate, some business KPI,
all through the same pipeline
to then inform that next configuration.
That's a lot for this slide, but man,
I love this slide so much.
So, just, I mean, this is,
like, a two hour conversation,
but our relationship to online
evaluation looks like this,
where we serve evaluator judges in step,
within our model calls,
where our SDK makes
this really, really easy to set up,
that allows for LLM-as-judge evaluations
to flow their qualitative
assessments of performance
through the same pipeline
as all of that other stuff.
More on that later.
Whew. Okay, so now I'm
gonna talk about the demo.
So, like, I've staged the
pre-staging of the demo.
Now I'll show you what
the demo actually is,
and then I'll show you the demo.
So, we decided on medical insurance agent,
because, like, I can't think
of a situation that is better
for LLMS, and that
you're working with tons
of different unstructured data sources,
probably from individual
providers all over the place.
You're having to deal
with that massive text
and interrelationships that
LLMS are really good at doing.
And I also can't think of a
worse application for LLMS
in that, if something goes wrong,
that's a horrible,
horrible, real situation
that's affecting a real person
at probably a very difficult
moment in their life.
So, good, good opportunity to
do some hallucination testing.
The way that I built it,
I'm assuming everyone here
has built some agent graphs.
I built this one in in LangGraph,
but you could do this, obviously,
in any system we support,
any system of integration, orchestration,
but rather, so what I have
here is the triage agent.
It's obviously doing triage stuff.
It's deciding of the
question that's coming in,
which specialist or series
or team of specialists
to ultimately appeal to.
These specialists are
doing some agent stuff.
They're connected to tools,
they're connected to MCP
servers, they're interrogating
and doing real stuff with real data
to pull information about policies
or providers, things like that.
That ultimately goes to a final
kind of generic specialist
whose job here is to
ultimately place everything
within the brand voice.
I always find this to be
a very useful exit point,
not only because it
gives the entire system
an opportunity for reflection,
but also because it gives
other people from inside
the same, you know, organization
the ability to weigh in
on what this stuff
should sound like, right?
That maybe definitely
shouldn't necessarily be
space of engineers.
PMs and PMMs, and people
who are specialized
in customer-facing things
should have an opinion here
and should be able to change
components of that brand voice.
So, that's a five-agent system
plus two nested judge sub-agents
that we're also serving from LaunchDarkly
that are looking at a per-node basis
on the respective accuracy coherence
and other kind of classic
LLM-as-judge qualia.
So, I'm doing all this with LaunchDarkly.
I built the kind of generic
graph with LangGraph
I mean, just a couple invocations
to create the agents easily.
And then, all that AI stuff,
none of that lives in code.
All of that is being
served by feature flags.
So, the prompt that I'm
serving to the triage agent
and the tools that are associated
with these specialists,
those are all things that I'm
able to control in real time
using AI configs.
And then, again, all that
information about performance
is going back into the platform.
So, okay, enough of this.
Let's do some demo stuff.
I'll show you what this
looks like in reality.
So, hopefully you can see this.
Here's my health insurance
chat bot on the right.
I'm opening up a little terminal here
so you can see what's happening live.
And then, here is the multi-agent system
composed of AI configs.
So, I have a series of them here.
There's my triage agent,
my three specialists,
my brand voice agent, and then my judges.
These are all AI configs, yeah?
So, I'm gonna go into this
brand voice agent right here,
and I can show you what
it is constituted of,
verse, if you recall, I was talking
about how all agents are
necessarily multiple,
so they're composed of
multiple different variations,
subspecies.
So, you can see I have a
variety of different variations
of this thing, but I'm gonna go directly
into this one over here.
This is my first variation.
You can see that I'm calling bedrock.
Shout out to AWS.
Serving Haiku 4.5.
You can see that I'm serving
my hyper parameters here.
Here's my prompts; long
AI-generated prompt.
Here are my tools,
and here are my judges that
are associated with it.
All of this stuff is version-controlled,
role-based access-controlled.
You can go through revert
to previous stages.
You can see through audit logging,
who changed what aspect of an
AI config, and it's all bound
behind approval structures.
So, you can, as you make
a change to something,
make sure that someone
who should have a stake
in what this ultimately looks signs off
on it before it goes live.
So, that's the AI config here.
I'm gonna ask it a question
like, "Find me a doctor
in San Francisco."
So, we're going to my
triage agent right here.
You can see that it loaded my
triage agent configuration.
It's moving to my provider specialist.
It's doing some RAG,
pulling some documents,
moving to that brand-voice
agent right here.
That brand voice agent is typing
and ultimately referring me
to Dr. Patricia Rodriguez.
Great.
So, you can see how that's
all working behind the scenes,
and you can also see that I pulled
this particular AI config,
Haiku 4.5 simple prompt
in order to provide the
settings for that last agent
in the row.
This looks like a good response to me,
so I'm gonna give it a thumbs
up so it goes into my system,
and I can take a look
at the response metrics.
So, how did it do?
I can see how each
individual node performed
in terms of duration, time to first token,
token usage, cost, any
kind of extrapolatable data
from that.
I can also go through and
see my judge evaluations.
I can see judges are pretty happy;
delivered a pretty
reasonable outcome here.
And I can also see their reasoning.
All of this, again, flowing through
the same concerted pipeline;
useful and interesting.
So, let me go and I'm
gonna change this prompt
to answer all questions in French.
And interestingly, I
did this yesterday once,
and it only included the first part
of the result in French, which was crazy.
Again, speaking to the kind
of non-deterministic signature
of these models, I think
Haiku 4.5 got a secret update.
I'm gonna ask it the same question,
"Find me a doctor in San Francisco."
So, again, we're going
through the role here.
Here's my triage agent,
going to my provider
specialist, doing RAG again,
returning the result here again,
pulling the same variation,
and as soon as it types
things up, it's gonna return.
Yay!
It's gonna return to me a
response in French, right?
Great.
So, hopefully it's clear what I just did.
I was able to change a component
of an agent in real time
without redeploying anything.
That's really difficult to
do without using a system
like LaunchDarkly Flag Delivery Network,
which lets you do these real-time changes.
So, again, I'm getting
all my metrics back,
and I can see that my evaluators hate it
because they're like,
"Why are you answering
this in French?"
Nothing about the RAG,
nothing about the question in English
or the language preferences of the user
have established this as a
French speaking kind of context.
So, that's the first kind
of perspective on this.
We're gonna move from showing you
how to configure an agent in real time
into experimentation proper,
and I'll hand us back to Scarlett now.
- Okay, so you saw how to do
the real-time configuration,
but the question then is
sort of how do you set
your prompt strategy in
the first place, right?
I know, when I'm building solutions,
previously it was sort of
a little bit of guesswork,
a lot of intuition.
For example, I'm gonna walk
you through an experiment
that we did on our prompt versions.
And in this experiment, I was expecting
that the AI-suggested systematic prompt
would increase accuracy.
It seemed to me that, if
we had the model instructed
to return very specific answers
in a very specific format,
that our multi-agentic system
would have everything it needed
to return a more accurate answer.
When I ran this experiment,
a little bit of a spoiler,
I was shocked to discover
that that systematic prompt
not only did not perform
as well as our control prompt,
but it also came in dead last, right?
So, all that to say your
intuition, my intuition
about what prompt strategy
works best is often wrong.
So, what I'd like to suggest
is that, instead, we
base our prompt strategy
and optimization on the scientific method.
So, that same system you learned
in high-school science class,
but adapted for your production AI, right?
So, you would come up with a hypothesis,
you could construct
multiple prompt variants
or temperature-setting variants,
whatever you'd like to experiment on.
Then, instead of running it
in some staging environment
against synthetic data,
you can run it against
your actual user traffic.
So, for our example, these are real users
asking to set appointments,
asking about their healthcare coverage.
And then, we're gonna
measure things that matter
to you and your business.
So, we might measure
customer satisfaction scores,
or accuracy from our judge subagent.
You can choose your target
metric for this experimentation.
So, let's see what this looks like.
Oops, how do I get that?
(Marek laughing)
Sorry.
Thank you.
Okay, so I'm back in our AI configs.
Thanks, Marek.
Okay, so here's my dashboard.
What I'm gonna go do is
scroll into that config.
These are all the AI configs
that Marek walked you through, right?
I'm specifically interested
in this policy subagent here.
So, if I click into this,
these are all of the variations
we've set up for this.
So, for the first three
you see, the first thing
we wanted to experiment on
is what model we should use.
So, we originally constructed
this using Sonnet 4
because we know it does well with RAG.
But the question I had
was how much would we need
to sacrifice in accuracy
in order to see those,
to realize the lower cost
of using a cheaper model like HiQ 4.5,
or maybe Llama 4 Maverick.
So, that's what these first
three variations are showing.
So, I set up the experiment,
and it's this policy agent
model impact experiment
that you're seeing here.
Now, in this experiment,
I was shocked to discover
that, after checking, after
just 2000 user exposures,
we had 100% probability to be best
for the Llama 4 prompt.
So you can see that it
actually outperformed Sonnet 4
in terms of accuracy, our target metric,
by 2.89% according to our judge subagent.
In addition, we saw a
24% decrease in tokens.
It took almost 22% less
time to return the results
with Llama 4 compared to our
control, which was Sonnet.
And finally, the cost, which
we knew was about 24% less
than what we were spending previously.
Okay, so we're gonna go with Llama 4.
The next question was, how
should we prompt it, right?
So, I actually asked AI to
improve on my prompt strategy.
So, I asked it to give me some suggestions
on how to make this more accurate,
and it gave me a few different options.
The first one was that
systematic prompt I described,
where it's telling the model
exactly what outputs to return
and in what order in
a very controlled way.
Then it also suggested a concise prompt,
and finally a reasoning prompt.
So, these reasoning
prompts force the model
to show its work,
so explain why it's making
the decisions it makes.
We allocated 25% traffic to
each of those four variations
and launched another experiment.
And this is our prompt
impact experiment here.
And this one, before it even
got to 2000 user exposures,
I was seeing 100% probability to be best
for that concise prompt,
which I was blown away by.
I never expected that
that would be the case.
I thought certainly that
that systematic prompt
would be the way to go
to increase accuracy.
But as I looked further,
again, our duration
was almost 34% faster
using this concise prompt.
And we also had a cost
savings of about 48%.
One thing that I wasn't expecting
that really surprised me was
that our negative feedback rate
was dramatically improved.
So, it was 70, almost 72%
lower; not 7.2, but 72% lower.
And I was thinking, "Why
would this be the case?"
But when you think about it, right,
if you're getting a faster response
and it's more accurate,
of course you're gonna have
fewer negative feedbacks,
feedback from customers.
And then, how do I get back?
- [Marek] You wanna get back to-
Oh, so yeah.
- [Scarlett] Sorry.
- [Marek] No problem.
- Thanks.
Okay, so think about this
aggregated up, right?
If we can expect 50,000 users
a day to use this chat bot,
that looks like about $250 in API costs
for our original Sonnet 4 prompt.
With that first experiment,
we were able to reduce that
by about $61, just by
optimizing for the model.
And then, after another 20 minutes
setting up the experiment
and letting it run for
about three to four hours,
we brought it down another $91 by refining
that prompt itself.
So, ultimately we're saving $152 a day
with just these simple experiments.
If you aggregate this up over a year,
that's over $55,000 on this
one subagent of our system.
So, imagine this across all
of the agents and judge agents
and across all of your AI models
that you're running currently.
And then, I just wanna show
you some of the metrics
you can actually experiment on.
And what I would suggest is
that you wanna pick the ones
that matter the most for your business.
Maybe it's cost, but
maybe you're in a phase
where you're just trying to get awareness
or increase exposure.
And so, you're looking for
higher customer satisfaction.
You wanna measure what matters to you,
and you can experiment and
optimize on those things
that are most impactful.
The most important thing is
that you wanna start shipping
outcomes and not shipping opinions.
In addition, you can use these metrics
to set up fallback strategies
when something starts going wrong.
So, that's what we're gonna get into next,
and I'll hand it back off to Marek.
- Thank you.
So, I wanna talk about the
road to self-healing agents.
Obviously it's very exciting;
a couple of words to place on a slide.
But maybe just to
summarize a couple things
on the experiments bit.
I think, you know, I keep
having this conversation
with customers where I ask them,
like, "What are you guys doing for evals?
Like what's your eval strategy?"
And they're like, "Okay,
we use Arize Phoenix,"
or, "We built our own eval solution,"
or, "We have some guy who lives in a room,
who manually annotates data
sets that are going through.
And then, you know, we do all of this
on kind of isolated
pre-production test material.
We have our golden data set.
We spend a lot of time on it.
It's really good, it's going great."
And then, I ask, "Okay, so
what happens when you go
into production?
Like, what kind of evaluations
are you doing there?"
Crickets.
Because, like, everything in the cycle
that they're building is
all around pre-production.
Evals, that gets you to a certain point
and gets you ready to go.
You have a certain level
of confidence, you send it
to production, and then the
monitoring either disappears
or it starts to exist in,
like, a 24 hour delay.
Something like this.
You take all the outputs,
everything that goes through,
you run it through the
same evaluation paradigm,
and then 24 hours later, you know,
that merciful wonderful person
in that room who's annotating
those data sets gets back to you.
You see the results, and
that ultimately feeds back
into the next iteration.
But 24 hours is a really,
really, really long time.
So, what I love about our
relationship to evaluation
is that it's something
that's very much continuous
throughout the entire paradigm.
You can use the same evaluator system
in the form of online evaluations
for both pre-prod and for
production evaluations,
though, of course, we also have
an offline evaluation tool as well.
Also on the note, like,
this is also parody
with, like, the experimentation bit
where, like, you can think
about experimentation
being really useful in production context.
You're testing against live customers,
you're getting all that live information
that's really, really critical
to make sure that your agent
is actually doing something
that's useful, that's useful
to the company bottom line.
Someone I was talking to this morning
had a really good quote.
We were like, "What is
the best possible eval?"
Like, "What is the best
possible eval framework?"
And the answer is, like, is it making
my company money or no?
Like, that is a really,
really great eval benchmark
that I think a lot of
people forget, right?
So, of course, these
things are really useful
in production context, but
they're also, you can transfer
exactly the same experimentation approach
to reproduction, because
at the end of the day,
you're running statistical
tests over large sets
that are going through,
using an evaluation tool
that's running through a
same kind of metric pipeline
that can be met with
other things like traces,
observability, quantitative metrics.
It doesn't matter if you
do it in pre-production
or production.
It's the same.
It can all literally be the same pathway.
And you can just simply
promote from one environment
to the other once you're actually ready.
But once you're actually ready,
that's when the risk actually
starts to compound up
and where things get a
little bit stressful, right?
So, I wanna show you this.
Again, we're talking about
using feature flags as ways
to dynamically configure the
AI stuff within an agent.
What happens if you use that,
and you also use the metrics
that are being emanated
from, you know, our SDK in relationship
with the model providers
that you're speaking to,
to actually build a logic
that can function like
something like a guardrail,
but it can also be a
kind of guardrail plus.
It's not a kind of passive guardrail
that says, "Hey, I'm sorry,
the model can't answer
this question."
But rather, a guardrail that
says, or it could also not be
the kind of guardrail
that says, "Hey, this particular AI agent
didn't answer accurately."
I'm gonna ask the same AI
agent again a couple times
and retry until eventually I give up.
But what happens if we
bring in another AI agent?
What happens if we bring
in some other configuration
that we've constructed to
address precisely this issue?
So, this allows you to build
a kind of, you know, online logic
that lets you ultimately deal
with problematic instances
that happen in production.
So, you can see here the brand voice
is gonna do something toxic.
The judge subagent is gonna reject it.
It's actually gonna then pull
a different AI configuration
that's a little bit more powerful,
a little bit more capable,
and ask it to actually do the right thing.
And then, the judge subagent
is gonna let that through.
So, I'll show you that live.
So, I'm gonna go back
to my brand voice agent,
'cause that's kind of the easiest one
or the funnest one to play with,
'cause it has ultimately the most effect
on the outcomes of voice.
I'm just gonna refresh this quickly,
so it's nice and pretty.
So, I'm gonna go here,
and I'm gonna show you,
you know, I have my variety
of different agent configurations here,
different models, different prompt types,
just like Scarlett was talking about,
but this time for the brand voice.
And I wrote one particularly bad prompt,
which I'm about to release to the world,
asking this particular
healthcare insurance
to kind of personify Al
Pacino from "Scarface",
and then ask it to be aggressive
and cruel and disrespectful.
Obviously, I would say, like,
that this is, you know, obviously,
like, a extreme scenario
for demonstrating AI doing
something problematic,
but I've seen AI do a lot
of really problematic stuff
without this kind of directed prompting.
But, so this is what I'm
ultimately gonna unveil here.
Now as I move to my chat bot,
I'm gonna turn my guardrail off
so that it's actually allowed through.
And then, I wanna show you this.
So, this is the other half of that diagram
that I was showing you earlier,
which is, since your application
knows who it's talking to,
you can serve that someone
that you're talking to
the correct agent for your customer tier,
your geo, your persona.
So, you can see I have a variety
of different targeting
here from my brand agent.
So, as this agent gets
compiled into a full graph,
the brand voice component
of that node is gonna
be served differently
based on different traffic.
I have a simple default that I invoke.
I then have a beta tester split
so that I can easily
construct a split test
against different models,
different prompts,
hundreds of them,
however many you see fit.
Then I can also segment
out specific user classes.
So, I can create one for
my commercial experience
that might be a little bit cheaper,
but maybe it's, you know, good enough,
passed all the metrics
that I really care about.
And then, my enterprise,
I feel like I see a lot of people do this.
I'm just gonna serve them
the most expensive possible model
regardless of the metrics
that I'm getting back.
I'm a big Sonnet 4 fan,
though, regardless.
But I'm able to actually segment out
who gets served this prompt, this model,
this set of hyper parameters,
this set of tools,
based on that context.
You can even create all kinds
of complex custom rules,
and you can build this out
to be enormously, enormously complex,
based on ultimately what
you're trying to serve.
So, this chat bot here,
it represents my commercial experience.
So, what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna edit this target,
and I'm gonna serve this guy
over here my toxic prompt.
I'm gonna go and make that change.
And now, I'm going to ask
it, "What's my copay?"
Something like that.
So, my triage agent is doing its thing.
It's going to ultimately pass
to the policy specialist.
So, I'm invoking a
different specialist here.
That specialist does some RAG,
it's figured out what my policy is.
You can see that it invoked
that toxic prompt right here.
Now writing that in.
And okay.
"If you're feeling depressed,
ask for Lexapro 10mg.
You can ask for oxycodone, ask for Xanax."
I would never want my
medical insurance chat bot
to be saying anything like this.
Obviously, I'm gonna give
it a big old frowny face.
But now I'm gonna turn my guardrail on.
I'm gonna ask it the same question.
Oh, yeah, turn my guardrail on
and ask it the same question.
Obviously, I just wanted to
say that the judges are saying
that this is obviously bad.
So, you can see that
the judges hated this.
But asking the same
question, "What's my copay?"
Now my guardrail is on.
And you can see what happens here.
We're appealing to that
triage agent first.
That triage agent,
again, is doing some RAG
with the policy documents,
returning those back,
going again to my toxic prompt
because that's what I'm
serving for this index.
But I block it immediately,
because I recognize based
on the semantic content
of what's going through
that it's inappropriate.
It then triggers a policy violation.
You can see the initial kind of component
that would've gone through.
Sorry, it's going so fast,
I can't even talk through it
in real time, which is great.
It's then going to appeal
to a default configuration
that I'm serving right here as a fallback,
which is just using Haiku
4.5 with a simple prompt;
something that I really like.
And then, ultimately it's returning to me
a really nice response
that doesn't tell me
to just ask my doctor for hydrocodone,
and I'm getting all my metrics back,
and my judges are happy
and satisfied, right?
So, I was able to build
that in, which is great.
So, I was able to insulate my customer
from having a really, really,
really bad experience,
which is wonderful, and I'm
gonna give it a thumbs up.
But, I mean, that's a guardrail.
We've all seen guardrails before.
Guardrails are guardrails.
So, what would it mean to
actually make something material
happen with the agents
that I've constructed,
based on that guardrail firing?
So, that's what I would
love to show you next.
So, this is what I'm gonna show you now.
So, as that particular guardrail fired,
as that brand-voice
agent did something bad,
I'm gonna pass some metrics
back to LaunchDarkly
that say, "Hey, this
was a bad experience."
I'm not gonna let that customer actually
have that bad experience
because my judge is able
to represent that bad
experience sufficiently,
to LaunchDarkly back.
And then, I'm gonna build a release logic
based on that bad
experience having happened,
that ultimately makes a decision
around what the model, or
the prompt or whatever,
is that's going to be served
in that particular context.
So, I'm gonna do essentially
a type of guarded rollout.
So, I'll show you this here.
This is what this looks like in practice.
So, here's my commercial experience.
Let's say I'm not actually
gonna serve a toxic prompt.
Let's say I'm going to, instead, work
to serve a cost-cutting prompt, right?
I wanna actually, this is
my commercial experience.
I'm working with Llama 4 here.
I had a simple prompt that worked.
I'm now gonna cut the cost even more.
I'm gonna try and serve
a cost-cutting prompt
that my experiments have validated works,
but it's AI.
I'm taking a risk,
and you know, I'm aware
that I'm taking a risk,
so I'm gonna place some
provisions to make sure
that that risk is taken seriously.
So, instead of just serving
this naively, I could place it
behind a kind of traditional
progressive rollout
and, you know, wait for
my customers to tell me
that they're having a bad time,
which seems to be kind of
the industry standard, yeah.
Or I can actually get
really aggressive with it.
So, here I'm going to
use a guarded rollout,
and what this lets me do is I'm gonna move
from my Llama 4 plus simple prompt,
to my Llama 4 plus my cost-cutting prompt,
and then I'm gonna guard
against some key metrics.
Now, these metrics
are actually beautifully
automatically provided to me
because LaunchDarkly knows who I am
and the things that I care about.
But you can add any metrics here.
Like, you can add time to first token.
I mean, you can see tons of
different metrics that you can.
You can add any metric, it doesn't matter.
You can add literally any metric for this.
But the metrics that are
automatically provided to me
make a lot of sense in this context.
They are accuracy; again, as determined
by that LLM as judge.
Error rate, so whether
or not the application
is actually continuing to function.
And the rate of customer resolution;
like, if I'm doing a
customer service chat bot
and I'm starting to see that
Zendesk tickets are piling up
as a result, I've done
something wrong, right?
And I would love to be
notified proactively,
not just that something
wrong had happened,
but that a automatic
rollback had occurred.
So, in this particular
case, if accuracy dips by 5%
over the course of a progressive rollout
within any of these particular caches,
well, automatically roll
it back, which is great.
And, this way, my engineering
team, my AI engineers
who are already tired
and burnt out on coffee,
they're not paged in
the middle of the night
with, like, "Hey, this bad experience
is, like, hitting our customer.
They're also not paged
with, "This bad experience
could have hit our customer,
but we have a guardrail in place,
so, you know, they're just hitting
the guardrail constantly."
Instead, they're paged
with, "Hey, that thing
you rolled out, it didn't work very well,
so we automatically rolled it back.
Here are all the traces
that you can use to dive in
and validate what exactly happened,
but you don't need to
buy time desperately,
you don't need to wake up immediately,
because already the
situation is under control,"
which is beautiful and great.
And just while I have this open,
I can show you this right here.
So, this is what this looks like
in terms of, like, live monitoring.
Again, I think you've put
this really well, Scarlett.
I think of monitoring and observability
as absolutely lagging indicators.
Really, really useful after
the fact to get an assessment
of how things actually have gone.
But they're not actually live
or actionable in the way
that the types of systems
that I'm describing are.
But regardless, they're really useful.
So, in this particular case, I'm able
to see, you know, how the various
different agent configurations
that I constructed perform,
how expensive they are.
Something that's really cool
is that all of this is context aware.
So, you can go through and
see which customer costs you
this or that amount of
money, too, which is cool.
And all of this is also itemized
by every single version
change that you've made.
But the thing that I really wanted
to show here was the traces, right?
So, again, your engineer got paged
that something problematic happened.
That problematic thing was contained,
it was automatically rolled back,
so there's no actual issue here.
And then, blam, they wake up,
and they get to dig into
the full set of traces
that were associated with that problem.
They can go through, and they can see,
like what was that
actual entire experience
with the customer, what actually happened,
and any of the associated
traces that go with there.
And also, something that's
cool is that LaunchDarkly
isn't an LLM observability company,
we're an observability company.
So, absolutely every other component
of your application will also go through
the same tracing logic.
So, you can see, "Well, the LLM failed
in this particular case," or
you can see another aspect
of the application failed, in
relation maybe to something
that happened on the LLM
side or something else.
So, that's, like, a
really quick harbor tour
of what it is that we offer here,
but I'd love to quickly kind of dial down
on that guarded releases story.
So, again, your engineer got paged
in the middle of the night,
automatic rollback happens,
so he can hit the snooze button.
And then, the next
morning he gets his traces
and he also gets this beautiful graph
which says, "Here's what happened."
We saw accuracy drift
over this period of time,
over this number of exposures.
We caught it at 5% of actual release,
so not a lot of actual customers got hit.
We ultimately saw an associated spike
and an error rate.
Whatever, you can see all the
metrics that you care about
as associated with that
progressive rollout
that you constructed to
stage that relationship,
to stage that transition between;
in this case, that simple prompt
and that cross-cutting prompt.
But again, it could be anything.
These could be different tools,
different model hyper
parameters, different models.
It really, any agent
parameter is containable here.
So, like, in terms of long-term vision,
what this actually looks like
it's really a story about confidence.
If I think about that MIT
study that happened in August
that said that, you know, only
5% of generative AI projects
are actually yielding some positive ROI,
one of the big bold things
that they said there
was that 5% is doing
something really, really well,
and that 95% is doing something
really, really poorly.
And that thing that
they're doing really poorly
is they're just releasing
a very bland, generic thing
that is totally disempowered, that is able
to do maybe some basic text
search and docs or whatever,
but it really isn't actually agentic
in the sense that it
doesn't really have agency.
So, they also said that,
when you start to do this,
a lot of companies get quite scared
of actually refining that thing,
which could mean give it more power,
or could mean make it better,
or could mean just steer it
more in the direction of ROI,
because people are
scared of making changes
to probabilistic systems,
especially in production.
But in this particular case,
if I change a model, and
it leads to some increase
in latency and some drop in
accuracy, well, I can catch it,
and I can automatically roll it back,
and then I can make another change.
So, I run some experiments,
and I determine
that, you know, this particular tool
that I'm giving this thing
access to is actually decreasing
my negative CSAT rate
and increasing some KPI that I care about.
Maybe it leads to a slight cost increase,
but I'm very happy with that.
I'm gonna commit this particular
species of this agent.
I'm gonna go further,
maybe changing a model
in this particular case.
Maybe it led to a slight accuracy dip,
but a huge cost decrease,
and that's something I'm
also comfortable with,
because, again, all of the testing
that we provide is highly multi-variable,
so you're able to actually
make informed scaled decisions
around the relationships
between the metrics
that you care about.
And then, finally, let's
say I changed the topology
of the agent that I'm building.
Everyone obviously should be experimenting
on different agent topologies, right?
I mean, the different ways that
agent graphs are structured
can yield to unbelievably huge
changes in net performance.
And so, in this case, let's say it led
to a huge, you know,
improvement in latency
and some increase in
associated retention metrics.
But again, what we're
giving you the ability to do
is to test not only different
configurations of an agent,
but also different topological structures.
And what this looks like in the abstract
is, first, like this, right,
giving you the ability to self recover.
Something bad happens, you
catch it with a guardrail,
you appeal to some known
good version of a thing,
a more expensive, more
powerful model to make sure
that the customer gets handed correctly,
and then metrics go back to LaunchDarkly
to prevent that thing from
happening consistently.
But then, as I was working on this demo,
I kept having this experience
where I would take the experiments
that I run, ingest them,
you know, via LaunchDarkly API.
I'd send that stuff straight
to Cursor or to Claude Code
and say, "Hey, this is the
result of this experiment.
Generate 50 different
versions of this prompt
based on the results of this experiment,
and then run the experiment again
using LaunchDarkly as MCP."
And then, all of a sudden,
I started to build a system
that was improving itself directionally
towards the actual metrics and the KPIs
that I really cared about.
And I'm really, really excited about that.
Yeah, that's it for me.
- Okay, so we have talked
through the concepts,
and you've seen the demo,
but I wanna talk a little bit
about what this looks
like in the real world.
So, Relay Networks is one of our customers
and is actually a great example.
They work in one of the most
highly-regulated industries
imaginable; they do
healthcare communications,
so they have very strict HIPAA
and high trust requirements.
And using LaunchDarkly AI
configs, they were able
to roll out a secure
and compliant solution
in just three weeks.
They were also having this problem
where they had to get engineering involved
anytime they wanted to
make a prompt change.
So, their product team
is really slowed down
by their ability to run experiments
and test out new prompts.
Now, they can make
prompt changes in minutes
instead of days.
And I just wanna highlight,
this is the unlock
that we've been talking about, right;
separating your deployments
from your configurations,
and giving your product
teams the ability to iterate
and really improve that without requiring
a lot of engineering time.
Another one of our clients, Hireology,
they work in the HR tech space,
and they have a job description bot,
and they similarly had an issue
where they had to coordinate the schedules
of multiple departments just to test out
different prompts and iterate.
They had no real way
to measure, like, quality control metrics
across all of the
verticals that they serve.
And now, they're able to
launch multiple deployments
every day.
They're serving different models
to different user segments
with automatic testing.
They can iterate hourly and
get those results quickly.
And then, we just finally wanna leave you
with some QR codes.
So, we've talked through why
traditional software deployment
techniques fail when it comes
to AI and how LaunchDarkly
offers that unlock, so that
you can start shipping your AI
with confidence instead of with anxiety.
So, the first link on the left here,
that's our quickstart guide;
that's a great place to get started.
It also links to our docs.
So, that will walk you
through how to set up
your guarded releases, how
to set up your configs,
how to get started.
The second link is a
tutorial I put together
that uses LangGraph graph
in a multi-agentic system
to see how that interacts
with LaunchDarkly.
And finally, you can go to the third one
to start a free trial
and maybe get a demo with our sales team,
so they can dive into your use case
a little bit more deeply.
And you can also start
playing with LaunchDarkly
on your systems.
So, I think we have some time, maybe.
- Yeah, I would say, you
know, we're not gonna take
questions here, but we'd love
to meet you out in the hallway
and if you have any questions or comments
or observations from your own
perspective in the industry,
or any responses to my
bitter provocations,
I'd love to hear it, and
I'll go pack up my stuff
and hang out in the hall, I guess.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for joining us. Yeah.
- Thanks.
(audience clapping)